[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAIME GREEN: Pamela Paul is the
editor of "The New York Times
Book Review" and
oversees books coverage
for "The New York Times".
She's also the host of the
weekly podcast "Inside The New
York Times Book Review".
She's the author of five
books, and her latest
is "My life with Bob,
Flawed Heroine Keeps Book
of Books, Plot Ensues.
Please welcome Pamela Paul.
[APPLAUSE]
JAIME GREEN: Thank you
so much for joining us.
PAMELA PAUL: Thank
you for having me.
JAIME GREEN: Would you
like to kick things off
by reading a little
bit from the book?
PAMELA PAUL: Sure.
Let me ground it a
little bit by saying
that each chapter in this
book is named after a book
that I read at some
point in my life
and recorded in this journal
that I've kept of every book
I've read since I was 17.
And the titles themselves were
chosen kind of deliberately,
not because each chapter
is about the book--
because I thought that
would be incredibly
boring to read about.
This is not a work of
literary criticism--
but because there was
something about that idea
that kind of captures
what I wanted
to write about in that
chapter, something
about the way in which
we read affects our lives
and forms our lives,
and the sort of space
between reader and book.
So this is from a
chapter called Catch-22.
And the Catch-22 is
essentially-- well,
I'll start with
it, and I'm going
to read a little
bit from the middle.
"This is every
reader's catch-22.
The more you read, the more
you realize you haven't read.
The more you yearn to
read more, the more
you understand that you
have in fact read nothing.
There is no way to
finish, and perhaps that
shouldn't be the goal."
And I talk a little bit
about how as a child,
I felt very book deprived.
"Some of my particular
strain of want
is certainly due to
early deprivation.
Books were and
still are expensive,
and my mother almost
never purchased them.
To this day, she
waits for a title
to become available while her
name climbs up the library wait
list.
In my childhood bedroom, I
had one meager bookshelf whose
lower rung primarily
accommodated back issues
of 'Young Miss' and
'Seventeen' magazine.
With my $0.10 second
grader's allowance--
that was cheap even then--
ratcheted up over the years
into a weekly allotment never
to exceed $5, I didn't
have much money for books.
If I asked my mother for a
book, her standard response
was, get it from the library.
There wasn't much you
could say back to that.
Our house, a creaking
hulk built in 1673,
had actually been our
town's first library.
It had long ceased to
serve in that capacity,
but we were just
around the corner
from the existing library,
which was directly
across from Main Street School.
After dismissal,
I'd cross the street
and install myself
for an hour or two.
While the library was, of
course, a public institution,
it felt private to me.
The children's library
shelves were mine.
I knew where my friends
Ginny and Geneva awaited,
and where the slightly naughtier
Klickitat gang hung out
at the end of the front row.
The mean kids from
'Deenie' and 'Blubber'
looked down from the high shelf.
These characters
provided my social life,
and I never had to be told to
be quiet in their presence.
I wanted to crawl
into the stacks
and absorb the musty smell
of decades-old paper.
I rifled my fingers through
the wooden card catalogs
like they were flip books,
trying to decode them.
I could be the first girl
to master the Dewey Decimal
System.
I might one day know
where every book stood.
All I needed was some
authority, or at least some kind
of officially sanctioned status.
A few years after
we'd moved to town,
I mustered the courage
to ask for a job.
'I'm sorry, there
are no jobs available
for children,' the
librarian told me.
I was 10.
'You wouldn't have to
pay me,' I insisted,
my eyes gleaming with what
surely came across as unhealthy
fervor.
'That's OK, but thank you.'
The rejection was terrible.
What was it that put
the children's librarian
off my candidacy?
Was it the 'you don't
have to pay me' part?
Did she question my intentions?
Could she not see
that I was a book
person different from the other
more casual library visitors?
That I cared?
That I would never leave a
book face down with its spine
splayed open like
other kids my age?
I couldn't help but feel
like they were taking me
down a notch. 'This
library isn't yours,
you know' is how I read it.
Every once in a
while, I'd gin up
the pluck to enquire
again, thinking maybe
they wouldn't remember
me for the last time,
sometimes asking at
the children's library,
other times going to
the person at checkout
with the enviable
task of scanning
each book through
the ghostly red glow
of the primitive
computer system.
These requests were
swiftly rebuffed,
and each time, I felt sorry for
having the temerity to ask."
I'm just going to skip
a little bit ahead
to what to me was like the peak
of my adolescence, which was
that I got a job at B. Dalton.
"Now this was a job.
I was the only high
schooler who worked
there, a monumental achievement,
and a source of fierce pride,
even if you considered there
wasn't much competition.
All the other employees were
actual grown ups, some of whom
saw the job as a calling, others
who could just as easily have
been working in the
produce section at the A&P.
Dan the manager was
one of the former,
a short, sweaty man
in his mid-thirties
with sparse tendrils of
black hair clinging hopefully
to his pate, and a mind
brimming with knowledge
acquired the hard way.
He greeted my
enthusiasm and ignorance
with tolerant dismissiveness.
He had opinions.
But I was determined to learn.
I would know
exactly what to read
and what I would read next.
My book of books would reflect
this clear path forward.
Here at B. Dalton, I
could keep my pulse
on the passions of the nation.
I just had to pay attention.
I quickly noticed, for example,
that whenever a book broke out
in a big way, someone
from management
ordered rising
swirls of that title
that spiraled majestically
up from the floor.
Only senior employees knew
how to build and maintain
these symmetrical assemblages.
Regular sales clerks like me
were not allowed to touch them.
Massive cardboard displays
known in the trade as dumps
loomed over the aisles, where
they signaled the defining
cultural events of the day.
Over here, pillars of
'Bonfire of the Vanities'.
Over there, an imposing tower
of Stephen Hawking's 'A Brief
History of Time', which everyone
in the We Are Sophisticated
suburbs just had to have.
I would caress this
slender volume longingly,
imagining that if I owned it,
my true place in the universe
would make itself known.
I envied the people who could
just stroll in and purchase
a few hardcovers off the
important towers with the swipe
of a credit card.
Somewhere along the main
aisles to the commanding dump
of 'Dianetics'.
These must be
important, I mused,
leafing through a title at a
copy during an idle moment.
'What do you think
you're doing?'
Dan barked.
'Just curious,' I said
guardedly. 'What is that?'
'You don't want to know,' he
muttered with a quick wave
of his hand.
I put down that L.
Ron Hubbard in a state
of unquenched curiosity,
too nervous to get
caught going near it again.
There were so many
mysteries that
eluded my beginner's grasp
of the world of letters.
'What's this?' I inquired,
holding up one of Joseph
Campbell's books on mythology.
Who was Joseph Campbell,
and why was he so important?
'What's this?'
I asked, pointing to a swirl
of 'Clan of the Cave Bear'
with the mermaid from
'Splash' inexplicably crawling
across its cover.
How did this book get to be a
movie, and what did that mean?
So many books indicated
something significant, yet
inscrutable.
Authors seemed to
have reputations
I couldn't quite deconstruct.
Stuart Woods dominated an
entire shelf-- a monolith
of contemporary letters?
Ann Rule, master of
criminal justice?
Then the threat of crime
itself came to B. Dalton.
In 1989, when the Ayatollah
Khomeini in Iran issued a fatwa
against Salman Rushdie
for his novel 'The Satanic
Verses', my colleagues and I
were swept into what felt like
a mission of global import.
The only time I'd given
thought to Iran prior to this
was during the hostage crisis
when someone graffitied
'Fuck the Ayatollah'
on a building
near Main Street
School, where it
remained for the rest of
my grade school education.
Every time I looked
at it, I thought,
'The world is full of
mysterious danger.'
But this current
danger was exciting.
I became nearly delirious in
my desire to sell 'The Satanic
Verses', spellbound
by photographs
of Rushdie's daunting
eyebrows and pungent gaze.
The tapping of cash
register buttons
was swiftly upgraded
into a campaign
to save literature from
the forces of darkness.
I blazed with excitement.
Each day, my coworkers
and I reported for duty
to get the latest
instructions direct
from corporate headquarters.
Copies of Rushdie's
book were to be
kept near the cash registers--
no, behind the cash registers--
no, in the back of the
store, the stockroom, where
only management could tread.
Employees who did not
feel safe selling the book
were allowed to be taken off
the schedule, no repercussions.
People were bombing bookstores.
Suburban customers who
couldn't for their lives
tell the difference
between Iran and Iraq--
I counted myself among them--
flocked in droves to our store,
whether out of curiosity,
for political
purposes, or simply
to feel part of something.
They skulked up to
the cash register,
saying in the hushed tones
of a John Le Carre character,
they wanted to buy the book.
'If somebody asks whether
we stock it or not,
think carefully before
you reply,' we were told.
'Answer on a
case-by-case basis.'
'What's the book about?'
I asked Dan.
'Nobody knows,' he replied.
JAIME GREEN: That's wonderful.
Yeah, I also worked in a
bookstore in high school,
and it felt like magic.
PAMELA PAUL: Yes, it's like
the greatest privilege.
But did you get a
better discount?
Because we only got like 5%.
It's terrible.
JAIME GREEN: I very
rarely bought the books,
because what they let us do was
we could borrow any hardcover
we wanted, as long as
there were multiple copies.
Because they wanted us to be
able to talk about the books.
And that's how I read the
first five Harry Potter books.
PAMELA PAUL: Oh, wow.
It's a much more
enlightened bookstore.
JAIME GREEN: Who knows.
So you allude very briefly
in that reading to Bob.
Not by name, but
can you tell us--
I want to say who,
because it's a name.
But tell us about Bob.
PAMELA PAUL: So Bob
is this journal.
He's still around.
JAIME GREEN: You
do use he for him.
PAMELA PAUL: I do.
He's a guy.
It's a really boring
looking blank book--
this is before Moleskine and
beautiful sort of Bespoke
journals--
that I started to
write in when I was 17.
I was living for a summer
through American field
service in France, and I was
incredibly disgruntled at this.
I thought it was going to be
a very glamorous expedition,
but instead I was sent
to a part of France
that no one ever writes
about, like a part that even
French people are like,
that's not France.
And I started to keep
a journal of the books
that I was reading.
Previous diaries that I had
kept I found were awful.
They were awful to
write in, and they
were awful especially to read.
Because what I
would write in them
was like angry, angsty
adolescent thoughts
of rejection and
embarrassment, and things like,
Katie said she was
sleeping at Wendy's house,
but I asked her to sleep
over first, and blah blah.
And going back and
rereading those,
it was like there was
nothing good about them.
They reflected
terrible feelings.
I couldn't even write well.
There was no glimpse of
any kind of literary skill
in those words.
And so I decided to--
and also, because I only wrote
about the times and the things
that upset me and depressed me.
They didn't make for
very fun reading.
And not enlightening either.
So I decided to keep
a diary of the things
that I did want to remember,
which was the books
that I was reading.
And I started off that
first summer in France
with 'The Trial' by Kafka, which
is what I was reading, and is
the name of a
chapter in the book,
because for me that
book was like a metaphor
for adolescence, where you feel
like everyone thinks that you
have done something wrong,
and you feel innocent,
and you feel like
everyone's out to get you.
And I've been keeping
that journal ever since.
JAIME GREEN: And it's
still in the same book.
PAMELA PAUL: It's still
in the same book, yes.
Yes, thank you for pointing
out that I've not yet
finished the Bob.
I thought I'd be like
on volume four by now.
The handwriting is very
small in my defense,
so I write it down
in tiny little print.
But I'm only half
way through, which
I guess makes sense,
since I'm probably
roughly halfway through--
a quarter of the
way through my life.
And so there's lots
of space to go.
JAIME GREEN: It seems
like a very private thing.
You write in the book
about just a couple
of times where you've
shared it with other people.
What does it feel like
writing about it publicly now?
PAMELA PAUL: Well, you
will note that in the book
there's only one image from Bob.
I've carefully put up a few
other pages on social media.
But no, it'd be incredibly
embarrassing to have someone
actually go through
the entire thing,
because of course you read
it-- and I should say,
I don't write about
the books in there.
It's just the title
and the author
and where I was when I read
it sometimes, and occasionally
a date.
I spent a lot of my 20s living
abroad, so a lot of that
is sort of about the
place where I was.
But there isn't
anything but the title.
So on the one hand,
that reveals nothing.
But on the other hand,
that reveals nothing,
because I could put
down a bunch of books
that I hated, and someone could
pick up my Bob and be like,
you read that?
Why did you read that?
And I'd be like,
well, I just wanted
to know, why is it so popular?
You read for all
different reasons,
and that's kind of what I wanted
to explore in my life with Bob.
What do you glean
from what you read?
Why do you read what you read
at a given moment in your life?
Sometimes you read again
out of stupid curiosity.
Sometimes you read on
the very first page,
which is in this book of books.
I have 'Interview
With a Vampire",
which I really wanted to like.
I hated it.
I hated that book.
And so that's one of the few
books that has a little I-N-C--
a little inc next
to it, which I wrote
for books that were incomplete.
But if somebody picks
that up and looks at it
and they were like,
Anne Rice, really?
So then they'd form some
kind of impression of me
that I don't know is necessarily
revelatory in the way I
would want it to be.
So "My Life with Bob", this
book is quite personal.
But in a weird way, it's not
as personal as Bob itself.
JAIME GREEN: Well it's at least
also written for an audience,
whereas Bob was very
much written for you.
PAMELA PAUL: Yes.
JAIME GREEN: And
this is much more
personal than the books
you've written before,
which were much more
reported and journalistic.
Had you always sort of had it
in your mind to write a memoir,
or did it surprise you when that
ended up being what came next?
PAMELA PAUL: I was shocked.
Even when I signed
the book deal,
I didn't know it was a memoir
until "Publisher's Weekly" was
like, Pamela Paul
to write memoir.
And I was like, oh my
god, I'm writing a memoir?
I thought it was a
book about books.
And my editors, they had to kind
of tame me a little bit from--
I kept trying to turn it into
a travel book, essentially,
and they were
like, we don't need
three chapters on Thailand.
And so the Brazil
chapter is gone,
and there aren't
three chapters--
I had so much to say about the
Xinjiang Autonomous Region,
but that didn't make
it into the book.
It is really personal.
And it's funny, when
I was writing it,
I thought, well, I'll just write
it the way I need to write it,
and it'll be really,
really personal.
And then when I'm all done,
when it's totally done,
before I hand it in,
I'll just go back
and I'll take
everything personal out.
I'll pretend like,
let me pretend
that my child is
reading this book,
and what would they think?
And then anything that I thought
would offend or upset them,
I'll take it out.
And then I just didn't do that.
So now it's all out there.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
And one of the things--
I mean, speaking of things that
could feel embarrassing to put
out into the world--
which I don't think comes
across as embarrassing,
but when you're writing
it feels scary--
one of the things that I was
really struck by in this book
is when you write about
your younger self,
whether it's 10-year-old
you inquiring about jobs
at the library,
sort of sweet ideas
that you had, or in your
20s and your romantic life,
and your teens, various
blunders or situations that you
got yourself into.
You write about all of that
with a lot of compassion
for your younger self.
And I'm curious.
Was it hard to write about
things that might have
felt embarrassing or awkward?
You already shared
one strategy you use,
which is pretend no
one's going to read it.
But what's your
relationship to younger you
as a character in the book?
PAMELA PAUL: So I
think that you don't
want to prettify your life, and
I think especially with memoir,
you want to access that
emotion in the moment
and be honest about it.
And for me, it's the primary
emotions of my life--
and they still continue--
are embarrassment.
And embarrassment not only
for me and my condition,
but I had contact embarrassment.
So if someone else trips
while walking down the street,
I on their behalf will blush
and feel totally tortured
for the rest of the afternoon.
And guilt-- pervasive guilt. And
guilt not only for the things
that I have committed,
but guilt for everything
that I may not have done,
and yet other people
may think I have done.
And then guilt for everything
that everyone else does.
And those feelings were
with me from childhood.
And I write about
reading this book
that the comedian
Sandra Bernhard wrote
called "Confessions
of a Pretty Lady".
And she writes
about walking down
the street picking her nose.
And that stunned me as a
child, because I was like,
I walk down the
street just trying
to look like a normal person.
And the fact that
you're flagrantly
violating the law by
picking your nose,
it just was so shocking.
And again, I was able to easily
access those feelings when
I started to think about
the books, because for me,
my childhood I felt so different
from everyone else-- which
everyone I know feels, or
almost everyone, unless they're
abnormal-- unless they truly
are different, in which case
they feel like they're
the same as everyone else,
and that's what makes
them so strange.
But because I felt that
way, I felt like books
for me provided a kind
of refuge and a place
where I felt accepted.
So that's what I wrote.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah,
it comes through.
As I was reading, I
was really surprised
that this kid who is
so intensely concerned
about all of those
things and felt--
I'm going like this,
so I guess young you
felt a little anxious
to me, or just
concerned about what
was right, and sort
of staying on that path.
And then in your teens and
20s, you traveled so much.
And not easy travel, either.
Not just France.
PAMELA PAUL: Had to torture
myself as much as possible.
JAIME GREEN: And so first that
was inspired by a book, right?
PAMELA PAUL: So I
was a good student.
I went to an Ivy League college.
I was going through the
job recruitment process.
My senior year, I had
like a very clear path.
I thought I was going
to work for like some--
I thought what I
was going to do was
I would either work in
publishing or in advertising,
but I basically--
any fancy corporation that
came to campus to recruit,
I was on their schedule.
And I remember I was in an
interview with Quaker Oats,
and they were like, why do you
want to work at Quaker Oats?
And I started to be like--
I don't know what I
said, but the part
where I gained consciousness
of what I was saying, was I
was like, and I really like
Quaker Oats Captain Crunch,
but only with crunch berries.
I don't really like it when
it doesn't have the crunch
berries.
And then suddenly I was
like, what am I saying?
Is this what I want
to do with my life?
And then I just had
this kind of experience,
where you'd see yourself
from a bird's eye view,
and you're like, what
are you talking about?
And I just stopped talking.
And I was like, you know what?
I don't want to
work at Quaker Oats.
And I walked out, and I decided
at that point that I would--
what I thought was
maybe the options
that I've been exposed to up
to this point were A through D,
and I don't even know
what E through Z are.
And I therefore want to try to
do something unlike anything
that I've ever done.
So I decided I would
go to a country
where I didn't
speak the language.
I didn't know anyone.
I didn't have a job.
I didn't have any friends.
It was a different religion.
I was an ethnic minority.
And I picked out like a few
countries that fit this,
and also that I didn't
have any interest in,
and that I thought I
might hate living in.
Just to kind of
really push myself
to every possible extreme.
And I came up with
a list of countries,
and then I narrowed it down.
I also didn't want to live
in a big international city,
because I'm from New York.
And I thought, what's the
point of just going to Tokyo?
And you can do everything
you could do in New York,
pretty much.
So I moved to Chiang
Mai, which was a city
of 100,000 people at that time.
A town, basically,
in northern Thailand.
And this was before
the internet,
so back then, moving
somewhere like that
was even more extreme
in that I didn't
have any contact with anyone.
I didn't own a phone.
I didn't have-- there was no
mail delivery to where I lived.
And my neighbor had a phone, and
so every other week-- and phone
calls were super expensive--
my parents would call me
at a certain time, and
I would talk to them.
But the object of
that travel was
to constantly put
challenges in front of me
and make it deliberately
difficult and unpleasant.
And the book
inspiration for that
was a book called "A Journey
of One's Own, Thoughts
for the independent
Women's Traveler" I think
is the subtitle,
by Thalia Zepatos.
And Thalia Zepatos
was this woman
who had ridden camels through
the deserts of Africa,
and had done all sorts
of things that I thought
I would really hate doing that.
And I thought, well, I
guess I'll try that out.
And it one of those things
where I felt like at the time
like 5% of me made that
decision to do that and drag
the other 95% along.
And I just bought the
nonrefundable ticket,
and then it was too
late to change my mind.
Plus I told everyone on campus,
and I called my parents,
and I was like, now it's just
too embarrassing to be like,
you know what?
Maybe I don't want to
do something that hard.
Maybe I just want to
get a job in New York.
But anyway, I did
end up doing that,
and it was probably the
best decision I ever made.
One that I don't feel
entirely responsible for,
but nonetheless
was the best thing.
JAIME GREEN: Why
was it so great?
Was it as unpleasant as
you thought it would be?
PAMELA PAUL: No, no,
it was fantastic.
No, it was really fantastic.
I mean, there were aspects
of it that were hard.
And again, that was
partly of my own doing.
I decided at a
certain point that I
would go to China for six
weeks on a budget of $15 a day.
And this was in 1994,
so that budget--
which was ludicrous.
But I just set the budget.
I didn't really
have extra money,
although I suppose I could have
begged, stolen, or borrowed.
But that's what I had.
And so there were times when I
was so strict about the budget
that I was like, no, I cannot
take the bed with the blanket.
I shall sleep on
the concrete block.
But even that was such a--
I was sort of trying
to see what that
would do to me as a person.
I kind of felt like
up until that point,
I'd had it too easy, and
that I needed to sort of mess
with myself a little bit.
But even though in the
day-to-day some of that
was difficult, ultimately it
was incredibly satisfying.
And it taught me
something that has
stayed with me throughout
my life, which is that--
up until that point,
I'd had this really kind
of foolish idea that
life was like a path,
and that every sort of task and
accomplishment that I could do,
I did.
And I checked off my list, and
I got to the Ivy League college.
And then I could
have gotten the job.
And then I was like, and
then you get the job,
and then you get the promotion,
and then you get the boyfriend,
and then you're engaged.
I thought that
that's what it was.
And I thought that by
getting off that path,
that when I got back
from living abroad,
that everyone else would be
like a few notches ahead of me,
and I would have to spend the
rest of my life catching up.
And so it was revelatory
to me at the time that no.
Within you a year, we were all
basically in the same place
just doing different things.
And that enabled to me a
little bit later in my career
to also make some
abrupt changes.
At one point I got up, I
just quit a brand new job
that I had at Time Inc.
that was a big fancy job
after three months to move to
London, kind of on an impulse.
And then later on, after
working in media companies
on the business side,
it sort of enabled
me to have the
courage to quit my job
to become a full time writer.
And I don't think
that I would have
been able to do those things
had I not had that experience.
JAIME GREEN: When you were
in those other countries
living that
challenging life, what
did that do to your
reading tastes?
Did you want to read
comfort reading,
or were you reading
books about the places
that you were traveling to?
PAMELA PAUL: It depended.
when I was in Thailand,
when I first got there,
I basically clung to
English literature,
which is my comfort literature.
It's like Thomas Hardy.
Like, I wanted to read
about comforting farmland,
and families in drawing
rooms, and that sort of thing.
That was my way to--
it was like a mooring for me.
And then later on
when I was traveling
in Vietnam and Cambodia, I did
read a lot about those places,
because the reason I had
chosen to go to Thailand
was because I really--
I truly had had no
interest in it at all.
All I knew about Asia with
like Benihana restaurant,
don't like it, and that Michael
Creighton book, "Rising Sun"
or whatever.
That was it.
That was my knowledge
of all of Asia.
So I did a lot of
reading about it
when I was there,
because I wanted
to know what I was seeing.
So before I went to Vietnam, I
read a lot of war literature.
Before I went to Cambodia, I
read a lot about the genocide,
and a lot of the history
of those countries.
So it was an
education, certainly.
JAIME GREEN: So you were saying
that your career has taken
a sort of non-linear path.
And you were working
in media, and then you
started doing some
freelance writing.
And then you left to be
a full time freelance
writer for a while.
Was it straight from there
to the "Times Book Review"?
PAMELA PAUL: Yes.
What happened was I had
worked on the business
side in a number of media
companies and documentary film
and in television and
publishing and in magazines,
and I quit those jobs
to write my first book.
I had started freelance
writing on the side
for "The Economist".
I wrote a weekly column on
arts, and I loved doing that.
And I did that at night.
And that was my fun time.
And I felt like I
sort of went to work,
and sort of paid my
dues during the day
and did what I loved at night.
And it was almost
like I thought it
would be too good to
be true to actually
just be writing all day.
But when I got my first
book deal and when I did
quit my job to write all
day, it was so amazing.
It was truly what I wanted
to be doing with my life,
and what I had always wanted
to do, but had suppressed it,
because that would be too good.
And I decided that I would
never go back to working--
to doing anything
other than kind
of being immersed in words.
And so I freelanced for a
long time for "The Economist",
and then I was writing
primarily for "Time".
A couple of books that I
wrote came out of stories
that I did for "Time"
during those years.
And then I started
freelancing for "The Times"
for various sections
of the paper.
The paper, that's like
a verboten word now.
But the news organization.
And I started
freelancing for those.
And then the editor
of the book review
was looking for a
children's books editor.
It was a full time job.
And he knew I didn't want
to get a full time job.
Like, I basically never wanted
to work in an office again.
And I liked being in my
pajamas all day writing.
So he asked me for help finding
a children's books editor,
because it's a great job.
At that point there'd only been
five children's books editors
in the history of
"The New York Times".
And I was like, well,
obviously I don't want it.
And he's like, I know you
don't want it, but help
me find someone.
And I did try to help
him, but eventually, I
thought none of these people
would do as good a job
as I would.
Which I realize is
incredibly obnoxious,
but I really love
children's books,
and I believe in
them passionately.
And though I hadn't worked
in them for a long time,
I kind of thought that I could
do a good job if maybe they
could make the job part time.
So on a whim, I emailed him.
And I was like, well, maybe if
you made this thing part time.
And within a month, I was
sitting at "The New York Times"
doing that job.
So I basically Dick
Cheney-ed my way
into the position, because I was
supposed to find someone else.
And that's how I ended up there
and then became the features
editor, and then the editor.
JAIME GREEN: So first, you spend
your days editing book reviews,
and you write books.
Is it hard switching
between the critical
and the creative mindset?
PAMELA PAUL: That's
a very good question.
You know, it's kind of--
I don't know.
I wonder if you were a
handyman, you'd be like well,
now I'm going to
fix the bath tub,
and then I'll work on painting
the walls and patching it.
They're within the same
family, but different skills.
And I kind of like
doing multiple things.
So to me, it feels like a
little bit of a palate cleanser.
And writing, I should
say, is something
that I don't generally do
too much of in my day job.
I wrote this book
on the train, and I
felt like it was my treat
at the beginning of the day
and at the end of the day
to dive deeply into reading,
albeit only for 38
minutes, which was--
it could have been longer.
Like the one person that
wanted a longer commute
so that I could finish a
chapter, or at least a page.
But they are different skills.
And I felt when I
was a freelancer too
that switching between magazine
writing and newspaper writing
and book writing was similar.
Sometimes you think of it--
the most negative way
to think about it,
but it's actually
a good thing is
that when you get sick of all
the things that bother you
about writing magazine
articles or whatever,
you can go into the book.
And then you get incredibly
annoyed with certain things
about books, so then
you get to switch back
to magazines and newspapers.
So I feel like I get to
do a little bit of it
all, and it works out.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
I know there are some
writers who don't
read reviews of their own work.
Do you read your reviews?
PAMELA PAUL: Yes.
I read them, and I
dissect them, and I
find every negative thing.
Yes, I read my reviews.
And also, there's a third
category of authors or people
who just don't believe
anyone who says that they
don't read their reviews.
So I have had people
very adamantly
tell me that they don't
read their reviews,
and then get very angry
at me for the reviews
that we've run in
the book review.
JAIME GREEN: Question over here.
AUDIENCE: I've just started
keeping a book diary myself,
having obviously
read for a long time.
But I enjoy having the
opportunity having them
written down.
I find my memory is selective
at times where people ask me--
or I ask myself-- what
did I read last month?
And I have no idea.
No idea what I read last month,
until I see it on the page.
And then I remember
everything about that book.
So I think I agree with you,
just the act of title, author.
I don't need to write a
review, because I remember it.
That's enough for me.
But I'm also at
this point in life
becoming more courageous
in not completing books.
How do you feel about that?
I mean you mentioned
that with Anne Rice.
Also a book that
I wanted to love,
"Interview with a Vampire", and
found it incredibly mediocre.
PAMELA PAUL: Yeah,
it's interesting.
I don't believe
quite as religiously
as I once did about finishing
every book that I start.
Because for me, the
decision about what
to read next very much has to
do with my mood at the moment.
It's like movies,
where you're like,
I'm not in the mood
for a thriller.
I want something-- so I
feel that way about books.
In a given moment, I want to
read something that fulfills
some kind of emotional need.
And so sometimes
I'll start a book.
And It's not necessarily
that I don't like the book,
but I find that this isn't this
isn't what I need right now.
And so I'll put it
down for a later time.
And I think one of the benefits
of having been in this world
for so long is that I have
a pretty good idea of what
I want to read.
So I don't have as
many false starts
as I did when I was a total
idiot ignoramus working
in B. Dalton when I was 17.
I try to--
I'm pretty strategic
about what I read.
But I also-- and I wrote
an essay about this
on the op ed page of "The New
York Times" a few weeks ago.
I believe strongly
in reading things
sometimes that I don't
like, that I disagree with,
that I find possibly even
offensive, just to get myself
into a different
mindset for a while.
And again, that goes back
to that weird tendency
I have to challenge
myself or to like almost
put myself in a kind of
situation of discomfort
on purpose.
So I will sometimes
finish books,
even if I really hate
them, just to kind of get
an understanding of what it is
that is bothering me so much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I agree.
JAIME GREEN: It
sounds like you're
following your heart and your
interest in what you read.
Do you not have to do a ton
of reading for your job?
I'm surprised that you get to
decide what you read, instead
of like, here are the
10 new books coming out
in the next few months
that I have to read.
PAMELA PAUL: You
know, I should pretend
that I do read all of that.
But the dark secret is
that I don't necessarily
read everything that we cover.
I am very good at
reading around things.
And I do get involved--
there are a lot of books
that I do read that have
to do with my work life.
And especially the end of
the year when we pick out
our 100 notable
books of the year,
and our 10 best books of the
year, that's a collaborative
process that I'm involved in.
And you have to read those
books in order to weigh in.
But I'm pretty
selfish as a reader.
This is the thing that I do.
I don't go to concerts,
and I barely watch TV.
I actually feel like I
should be watching TV,
because it's so good.
So this is my pleasure, and
I guard it a bit jealously.
JAIME GREEN: One thing
you say in the book
is people have limited time for
books, and the job of reviews
is to help them make choices.
And that's in the
context in the book
of dealing with having to
write or edit negative reviews,
and loving books, and
wanting to be positive.
But also wanting to help
people make choices.
So I guess my first
question is, do reviews help
guide your reading choices too?
PAMELA PAUL: They do, but
sometimes a negative review can
make me want to read the book.
Sometimes I read
a negative review,
and I think about the reviewer,
and that reviewer's voice
is coming through, and
I'm like, you're a jerk.
I don't like your
opinion, and I'm
going to read that
book that you say
is so terrible, because I
think I'm going to like it,
because I don't like you.
So I think a negative review
isn't always a bad thing.
And at "The Times",
we're journalists,
and we are trying to guide and
illuminate the world of books
for our readers.
So we're not promoters of
books, although of course we all
believe in them.
We wouldn't be working
at the book review
if we weren't fans
of the format.
But the other thing
that I should say
is that a lot of
negative reviews
come in from our critics, who
many of them are freelance.
And we don't share their
opinions necessarily
as the editors.
Sometimes we'll send out
the book, we love it.
The review will come
back, and it's negative.
But again, it's a newspaper.
We are journalists.
And what we do is we
don't edit opinion.
We're not going to
change their mind.
So we run those
negative reviews.
And then everyone
gets angry at us.
JAIME GREEN: And you're
sitting there silently saying,
I know, me too.
PAMELA PAUL: Yes.
The hardest is when we have
negative reviews of books
by my colleagues,
which does happen.
And then we're sort of
like department non grata
at "The New York Times".
JAIME GREEN: That must be tough.
PAMELA PAUL: Yes.
It's like it's--
I'm trying to think
of the equivalent
here at another company.
But to get a negative
review in public,
I don't think people
often think about what
that feels like to be
on the receiving end.
Like, imagine you're
a software engineer,
and a colleague writes
up a thing and is like,
you know what?
First of all, I see the way
that guy manages his time.
He was on Facebook
for like 45 minutes.
He was blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
And then they post it
publicly for everyone to read.
And that's what it is like
getting a negative review.
One of the advantages I feel
like I have at the book review
is that I have gotten
negative reviews,
and I've given negative reviews.
So I feel like I
know what it feels
like on all different sides.
And when I write
a negative review,
having gotten what I think
are horribly unfair, unkind,
and not true negative
reviews myself,
I try to be
respectful of the fact
that a book takes a
lot of time to write,
and is often sort of dear
to the heart of the writer,
and to point out what
the writer did well,
as well as what
the book got wrong.
And not to attack the
writer, but to really
critique the book, and
to keep that separately.
And there are a lot
of things that you
can do in a negative book
review that are unfair.
Like you can use a book
to advance an argument
that you already have
set in your mind.
You can go into a book
not as an open reader,
but with your own argument,
and then read it in such a way
that you're sort of
cherry picking things
out to support
your point of view,
and then write a
book review that is
essentially more of an op ed.
And those kind of things I
think are incredibly unfair.
So I try not to run them.
And when we get
those kind of reviews
in, even if we can only edit
them to a limited extent,
those writers usually are
not invited back to review.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
We have another
question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, yeah, this
is to kind of go back to--
I think we were talking about
it right at the beginning.
But I love the idea
of a tiny Pamela Paul
at the library asking for a job.
That is so darling, and I love
that kind of precociousness
that a lot of kids have.
And I think it's interesting.
I mean, I work with
Jaime on the books team.
We have a whole
editorial program here.
I think we've all
worked at bookstores.
A lot of us have studied
literature, philosophy,
have at one time wanted
to be a librarian
obscure French philosopher,
professor, something like that.
So I guess I wonder, when
you and your colleagues
on the inside of "The New
York Times Book Review",
and talk about like-- well,
you talked about Victor Hugo
forever when you were
reading that book.
PAMELA PAUL: Yes, forever
being the key word.
It took a long time.
AUDIENCE: Or your
colleague, you just finished
"The Power Broker".
You can tell you
guys all probably
have a similar childhood story
of being kind of inexplicably
drawn to books and to reading.
And so I don't really
know, the question
is kind of an absurd,
existential question.
But what do you
think that's about?
What did draw you to
want a job at the library
when you were a kid?
PAMELA PAUL: It's
funny, when you
describe that, I think of that
old movie "Freaks", you know?
And there's that horrible scene
at the end of freaks, where
all the freaks are around
a table, and they're going,
one of us, one of us.
And that's like the dorks
of "The New York Times Book
Review" where it's like,
I am among my people.
One thing that we have in
common when you sort of grew up
reading more than
you did talking,
and you weren't
well-socialized, is
that you mispronounce things.
So before we go on the
podcast, we're often like,
wait a minute, how
do you say that?
And yeah, we all mispronounce
things all the time.
But I mean, I think we all feel
incredibly lucky to be there.
There are three
colleagues that I
have at the book review
who've been there
for more than 30 years, because
it's the kind of thing--
like, if this is
what you like to do,
this is where you want to be.
And unfortunately, there
aren't-- we're the last
freestanding book
review in the country.
"The Washington Post" folded
Book World into Outlook
in 2008.
And the one before that was
"The San Francisco Chronicle",
which folded in 2005.
So I think we all
feel like we've
gotten to where we need to be.
In terms of what it is that
makes people end up in a place
like this doing
this kind of work,
I do think that one
of the things that
marks my colleagues-- but
again, I think it's true
of many readers-- is
that reading for us
is not purely intellectual.
It's an emotional
experience as well.
And the thing that you
can't say on that podcast
is that people tear up.
We all feel very, very
strongly about what we read
and what we do.
So yeah, I don't know what
it says about us as people,
but there you have it.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
So I guess my last
question is, what have you
read lately that you've loved?
PAMELA PAUL: I don't have my
book of books in front of me.
I don't have my cheat sheet.
I don't remember things either.
That's why I have my Bob too.
It's my memoir.
So I am almost done with Ben
Bradley's memoir from 1995,
which is called "A
Good Life, Newspapering
and Other Adventures".
And that's a book
that I've been meaning
to read since it came out.
And I'm like, oh, I
guess I'll get to that.
I didn't realize
that I'd been meaning
to read it for 22 years.
But there are many books
that I have been intending
to read for that long.
And I love that.
I'm a big fan of biography.
And a novel that I read recently
that's pretty contemporary
that I adored was by a writer
named Chris Bachelder called
"The Throwback Special".
And this was an instance
of reading something
that I kind of thought
I wasn't going to like.
In fact, it's a
novel about football.
And as it becomes clear,
despite a brief period
of playing rugby in college,
I'm the least sporty person.
I mean, I will probably trip
on my way off the stage.
And so I would never
have read this book.
But what happened is that one
of my colleagues reviewed it
and wrote such an entertaining
positive review that I really
felt annoyed, because I thought,
now I'm tempted to read this.
And I don't want to read
a book about football.
I don't know a single thing
about football, let alone care
to know a single
thing about football.
So that happened.
And then the paperback
came in, and then it
had a little blurb
from the reviewer who
is on staff at the book
review on the front cover.
And I thought, darn
it, another thing
that's going to make me
want to read this book.
And then I had to interview
the author at an event
up at Amherst College for
the National Book Foundation.
And so I thought, well,
I've got to read it now.
And I loved it.
It's really great.
It's so funny.
And of course, even though
it is about football,
It's about the Theismann play,
for those football people
out there, which is apparently
this horrific injury that
occurred on "Monday
Night Football" decades
ago, that the football
people remember very
well, because the guy's leg
broken in a really unkind way,
and he never played
football again.
And the novel is about 22 guys
who get together every year
to recreate this play.
And so it's sort of like a Civil
War re-enactment kind of thing.
I mean, it's a guy
sort of ritual thing.
But ultimately, what
the book is about
is about midlife and manhood
and masculinity and friendship.
And I'm getting goosebumps, see.
We're very sentimental.
I loved it.
It was really great, and
it was so well-written,
and it was so funny.
And so I was one of
those annoying people
that any time someone came
into the room, I'm like,
I'm just going to read
this one paragraph.
And then it'd be like
two pages, and I'm like,
I'm only going to read
you just one other thing
that you just have to hear,
because it was that good.
JAIME GREEN: All right,
"The Throwback Special"?
PAMELA PAUL: Yes.
I recommend it.
JAIME GREEN: All right,
well, we're out of time now.
But thank you so
much for coming in.
PAMELA PAUL: Thank
you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]